bonjour à tous je vous propose dans un
stand écouter l'audition d'alain delcamp
devant la commission des lois du sénat
la commission des lois qui auditionnait
donc l'ancien secrétaire général du
sénat pour être nommé membre de la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique
je vous rappelle que le nom d' alain
delcamp a été proposée par le président
du sénat jean-pierre bel
et cette haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique a été
annoncée par le président de la
république françois hollande après le
scandale de la sphère cahuzac
la semaine dernière l'ancien haut
magistrat jean-louis nadal a été nommé
président de cette haute autorité
voilà tout de suite je vous propose donc
d'écouter l'audition d'alain delcamp bon
alors monsieur delcamp nous sommes très
heureux de vous accueillir
mais à vrai dire vous êtes chez vous au
sénat n'est ce pas et je ne vais pas
vous le comprendrez monsieur del camp
parce que vous allez vous même parler de
votre parcours
je ne vais pas avoir l'outrecuidance
devant mes collègues et devant les
administrateurs ici présent de vous
présenter vu que tout le monde vous
connaît donc je rappellerai vous avez en
plus reçu un document de six pages 5
pages sur wauquiez a condensé de vos
titres et travaux donc nous savons tous
que vous avez été secrétaire général du
sénat d'abord secrétaire général de la
présidence 2005 à 2007 et depuis 2007
juin 2007 secrétaire général du cdh a
donc nous le savons tous
nous avons tous plus
vous être en contact de travail avec
vous à de nombreuses reprises nous le
savons que vous êtes vice président de
l'association française de droit
constitutionnel
professeur associé au groupe d'étude et
de recherche sur la justice
constitutionnelle à l'université paul
cézanne qui doit être à aix-en-provence
et bien cela et que vous avez publié de
très nombreux ouvrages et je me souviens
en particulier d'un ouvrage que j'ai
toujours sur le sénat et la
décentralisation sujet qui nécessitera
bientôt un deuxième tome n'est ce pas
monsieur van d'irène donc et bien
entendu je laisse le meilleur pour la
fin
c'est que inévitablement après avoir été
recruté après avoir réussi le concours
d'administrateur du sénat ce qui est
difficile en et est rentré en avril 71
danse au sénat vous n'avez pas manqué
d'être durant huit années administrateur
à la commission des lois
car et puis et puis quelques temps après
ah mais c'est tout j'ai tout pendant
cinq années de 84 à 81 9 responsable du
secrétariat comme on dit de la
commission des lois
vous comprenez que quand on est dans
cette maison si on ne passe pas par la
commission des lois
il manque quelque chose alors j'arrête
là ce discours pour vous dire que nous
sommes bien sûr heureux de vous
accueillir mais que nous devons remplir
notre fils notre fils va être de vous
écouter
ensuite il y aura une série de questions
posées par les collègues puis mes chers
collègues il faudra revenir à la salle
de la commission où il faudra que nous
votions et je rappelle que pour la
première fois monsieur des deux camps
vont inaugurer un nouveau dispositif qui
fait que votre nomination devra être
approuvée pour être effective par les
deux tiers positif je me trompe toujours
les 3/5 positif des votants à vous avez
été près proposé naturellement vous
étaient proposées par monsieur jean
pierre bel président du sénat et c'est
la première fois que s'applique puisque
jusqu'à ce jour nous n'avions eu à
statuer que sur des nominations qui
nécessitent et le 3/5 qu'il n'y ait pas
de 3/5 négatif au début d'accord tandis
qu'à une fois trois cinquièmes des
votants des suffrages exprimés positif
pour mes chers collègues nous allons
maintenant donner la parole enfin à
monsieur delcamp alain delcamp monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
si je puis me permettre chers membres de
cette chaire commission des lois vous
imaginez je suppose malgré l'accueil
très très aimable que vous me réservez
l'émotion qui est la mienne de vous
retrouver ici en ce lieu
mais cette fois de l'autre côté de la
barrière
c'est aussi pour moi compte tenu de la
déontologie des fonctions que j'ai
exercé au milieu de vous et au service
de l'institution sénatoriales un très
grand honneur en même temps je me
réjouis de l'évolution institutionnelle
qui a voulu que les nominations
importantes face désormais l'objet d'une
validation parlementaire j'y vois le
double signe du rééquilibrage des
pouvoirs en faveur du parlement voulue
par la dernière révision
constitutionnelle mais aussi une
garantie pour la démocratie
je me réjouis aussi que cette audition
soit publique
cette publicité qui plus est télévisé
valide les choix faits par les deux
assemblées de se doter de moyens
audiovisuels indépendant à même de
permettre un meilleur accès par les
citoyens à leurs délibérations et à une
explicitation de leurs décisions
j'ajouterai un mot d'inquiétude car je
mesure les risques de ce dispositif
spécifique auquel je suis soumis
aujourd'hui puisque pour la première
fois une nomination requerra au sénat
comme elle a été la semaine dernière
l'assemblée nationale pour être approuvé
une majorité positives vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président des deux tiers et
non pas seulement les trois cinquièmes
et non pas seulement une absence
d'opposition à cette même majorité
je sais que cette inversion
correspondent aux seuls présidents un
choix qui vous est cher et que vous
souhaiteriez voir étendu j'avoue
partager quelques points quelque peu
sous point de vue mais c'est une autre
histoire
c'est néanmoins une exigence très
redoutable pour la personne auditionnée
et j'en mesure la difficulté
cette inversion de position sinon dans
une salle au moins devant une instance
la vôtre que j'ai servi vous l'avez
rappelé pendant nos maux année près de
20 années et en dépit du fait que vous
me connaissez tous encore elle rend
paradoxalement d'autant plus nécessaire
que je me présente à vous
en essayant d'insister sur le système de
valeurs qui le mien et que j'ai conforté
en grande partie à travers mon
expérience de fonctionnaires
parlementaires au sénat
j'ai grandi dans un milieu familial très
classique dans un département qui
pouvait sembler reculé jusqu'au pu la
lui dire d'être une de mes compatriotes
le département du cantal mais très
proche de ce fait des racines de ce pays
longtemps rural ordonné autour de ces
villages est plutôt dur au mal
c'est un pays d'exportation comme le
disait alexandre vialatte de l'ouverture
générale qui produit je cite des
ministres des fromages et des volcans
je trouve également assez juste
le qualificatif de jules michelet qui
voyaient dans ses habitants une race
méridionale qui grelotte au vent du nord
en fait comme le département est à
cheval l'école bonne foi il sait bien
est à cheval sur la ligne de partage des
eaux
le climat n'est pas tout à fait le même
suivant que l'on descend en pente douce
vers le sud ouest ou que l'on domine la
veille du rom pour simplifier et
originaire du côté ouest
je me sens en disant du midi moins le
quart
je lui suis reconnaissant de cette
architecture forte qu'il m'a donné
conforté par l'éducation républicaine
classique les sérieuses de ces grands
lycées de la troisième république
bâtie comme des forteresses j'ai
découvert aussi une forme d'injustice
les rivalités par exemple liés à la
guerre scolaire qui sévit sait encore
quand j'entrais en sixième
je n'ai conservé je crois sur instinct
de tolérance et un grand esprit
d'indépendance l'esprit de tolérance et
l'esprit d'indépendance se trouvèrent en
adéquation est renforcée par le climat
que je découvrais au sénat
le pluralisme abriter est garantie par
l'esprit d'institutions
le pluralisme et est le fruit de la
composition même du sénat et disons le d
caractère de son hôte de scrutin
aujourd'hui mieux compris si je me
réfère en tout cas à la dernière réforme
que vous avez voté l'esprit
l'institution était la conscience d'une
appartenance à une réalité singulière
qui est si elle possédait des pouvoirs
certains et souvent méconnu l'égalité
avec l'assemblée nationale en matière
constitutionnelle d'abord paraissait
sans doute à tort plus fragiles et au
moins inconsciemment tenu de justifier
son existence
ma rencontre avec le sénat fut fortuite
ce n'était pas une vocation tout au plus
la combinaison des études à paris où je
me trouvais depuis l'âge de 17 ans et le
hasard d'un référendum perdu par le
général de gaulle le concours de
recrutement d'administrateur de 1969 le
plus important depuis la guerre fut l'un
des signes du retour de la confiance du
sénat en son avenir
de fait l'inquiétude de ces années
incertaines resta lisible pendant très
longtemps je fus sensible à la
découverte de traditions politiques que
je ne connaissais pas qui avait subsisté
malgré le rouleau compresseur de la
république nouvelle aux nuances infinies
des terroirs à la singularité des
itinéraires aux solidarités
d'appartenance j'ai découvert une
institution en reformations faisons avec
le président poher le pari de son
ouverture vers l'extérieur
pas de nostalgie de la troisième
république
le même désir d'être apprécié que le
conseil de la république qui avait
conduit à la reconnaissance du
bicamérisme en 1958
ma carrière encouragé par l'heureuse
institutions de la mobilité n'a permis
au fonds de contribuer au développement
de ces deux versants de l'institution
l'ouverture et la permanence
l'ouverture c'est la diversité
d'activités qu'elle me permit aussi bien
juridiques ou de conseils que
d'administration humaine et gestionnaire
ce furent aussi les voyages à travers
les groupes d'amitié les missions à
l'étranger outre mer l'accueil des
délégations à paris tant d'élus que le
fonctionnaire la préparation ou la
participation à des rencontres
internationales au niveau mondial
européen ou de la méditerranée
l'assistance à de multiples auditions et
entrevues l'organisation de rencontres
et de colloques
le président monory avides de réformes
ne projeta dans un domaine qui ne
mettait pas familier celui de la
communication jean découvrir la réalité
- d'apparence qu'on ne le dit tellement
le vrai sujet de fûts savoie puis
d'abord de savoir quoi et comment
communiquer avant de penser aux outils
ce fut le temps de la diffusion
d'internet dans laquelle le sénat
s'affirma grâce à son président d'alors
comme un pionnier de la création de la
chaîne public sénat
avec l'apport inestimable de jean pierre
elkabbach des innovations événementiel à
paris et en province avec en liaison
avec les écoles les collectivités
territoriales les universités la
jeunesse le monde de l'économie de la
recherche
les créateurs de tous ordres les
expositions de photos sur les grilles
inventé avec yann arthus-bertrand toute
initiative poursuivi diversifiée et
amplifié par le président pons les et
qui contribuèrent à redresser l'image du
sénat et à surprendre la permanence ce
fut la participation au travail
législatif dans des contextes politiques
et institutionnelles très variable
puisque ma première affectation au
secrétariat de la commission des lois
intervint en octobre 1972
période le sénat était encore dans
l'opposition travail obscur patients que
j'ai pas besoin de décrire pour vous
continuent de nas surtout en commission
ou avant incertitudes de la navette
bonheur de la commission mixte paritaire
quand elle réussit témoignage de la
nouvelle lecture recours au conseil
constitutionnel
beaucoup d'efforts d'énergie autant que
de droit
le parlement est aujourd'hui peut-être
une des dernières institutions qui ne
comptent pas leur temps et les citoyens
n'ont pas suffisamment conscience une
institution très ancienne mais en même
temps si jeune si on la compare la
connaissance justement quand on pense
qu'à nos concitoyens et qu'ils ont
besoin de redécouvrir car cela
nécessitait résulte de l'idée même de
démocratie du gouvernement du peuple par
le peuple et pour le peuple
la médiatisation du parlement est
d'ailleurs une question qui demeure
certains se demandent encore à l'heure
de ce que l'on a appelé à l'assemblée
nationale la démocratie paparazzi si le
gain en terme de connaissances
médiatique la fameuse transparence peut
être mis en balance avec l'intérêt de la
poursuite infini du dialogue et de la
recherche patiente de position de
conciliation qui constitue la raison
d'être quotidienne des assemblées et de
celle ci en particulier travail
législatif dont on cancer entre souvent
parfois une image pointilliste mais qui
dissimulent toujours des enjeux concrets
et démocratique c'est-à-dire
l'affrontement ou parfaitement sain et
nécessaire d opinion j'ai assisté aussi
et participer au développement des
travaux tout contrôle sur le terrain et
en commission celui ci fut facilitée par
la position politique plus distancié du
sénat mais aussi par une conscience
aiguë est en général sous-estimé de
représentation du point de vue de
citoyen
face à un état administratif certes
affaiblie mais à qui il convient
toujours de faire contrepoids
j'ai eu la chance enfin dans ma carrière
d'éprouver toutes les facettes de ce
travail si particulier de fonctionnaires
parlementaires le travail législatif en
commission et en séance et la
communication certes mais aussi la
trésorerie ou le cabinet des questeurs
de découvrir et faire un peu évoluer
avec mes collègues les différents
métiers de l'administration sénatoriales
jusqu'à sa direction au plus haut niveau
sous l'autorité directe du bureau
plusieurs présidents ont bien voulu
m'accorder leur confiance
ce furent des moments d'intimité rares
toujours marqué qu'il s'agisse des
présidents poncelet larcher est belle
par le souci de l'autonomie du sénat
mais aussi de son utilité au service de
ceux qui les avaient élu je finirai ce
parcours peut être trop personnelle par
de notation qui me paraissent essentiels
dans le contexte de cette audition la
question de la déontologie est celle de
la liberté
la question de la déontologie est au
coeur de l'action publique
elle est indissociable de la situation
du fonctionnaire quel qu'il soit elle
prend au parlement une importance
renforcée car elle s'exerce non
seulement à l'égard de l'employeur
public mais aussi à l'égard de toutes
les familles politiques
celle-ci coexistent mais dans une sphère
qui n'est pas celle du fonctionnaire et
il doit aller servir également la
déontologie est affaire de règles mais
aussi de qualité morale et d'expériences
d'exemple aussi elle augmente d'ailleurs
à proportion de la position occupée dans
la hiérarchie la liberté 1 est
indissociable tout en étant aussi
nécessaire mais celle ci ne peut être
conciliée avec la déontologie
que par un effort permanent sans doute
assurément par une certaine ascèse bâti
autour de conviction institutionnelles
fortes
je ne crois pas que le politique attend
de ses collaborateurs une forme de
grisaille au contraire mais il a besoin
de pouvoir faire confiance et c'est là
où l'on rencontre notre thème de vos
débats celui de l'apparence fort délicat
à manier j'ai toujours pensé que l'on ne
pouvait servir le public a fortiori dans
un milieu où les positions publiques des
fonctionnaires sont exclus que si l'on
développé en parallèle sa propre éthique
dans des domaines compatible l6 explique
dont l'engagement dans l'université et
la recherche universitaires que vous
découvrez peut-être plus important à
travers ma bibliographie
je pense y avoir quelque peu servile
sénat en le faisant mieux connaître à
ceux qui transmettent le savoir sur les
institutions cette activité m'a aidé à
prendre et conserver une certaine
distance avec la quotidienneté de ce
milieu si prenant est si confortable à
la fois elle m'a donné l'occasion
d'affirmer hier quelques idées et
maintenus en éveil pour conserver je
l'espère un regard encore neuf sur les
choses elle demeure pour moi un aliment
pour contribuer même modestement à faire
évoluer ce vieux pays qui reste si je
puis me permettre
pour moi comme pour vous n'est vraie
passion un merci monsieur alain delcamp
pour cet exposé dont on voit bien que
vous l'avez longuement mûri écrit avec
soin je vais peut-être demandé à nos
collègues les questions qu'ils
souhaitent poser qui va poser la
première question
alors madame catherine tasca
oui merci monsieur le président je pense
que vous avez eu raison d'évoquer de
façon très précise détaillée engagé
votre parcours
car dans le choix qui nous est proposée
par le président bayle le facteur
personnel dans toute sa dimension de
connaissances et des tic est évidemment
un élément déterminant et j'ai envie de
vous poser une question sur
l'institution dans laquelle vous
entrerez si telle est notre choix c'est
la première fois pour le sénat que les
questions de déontologie seront traités
hors de ses murs par une instance
extérieure
vous connaissez notre attachement à
l'indépendance du parlement et à la
responsabilité de chaque chambre pour
gérer l'ensemble de sa de ces règles de
vie comment on pensez vous que cette
nouvelle institution pourra tout à la
fois remplir pleinement la mission que
lui donne la loi c'est-à-dire vérifier
en particulier à travers les
déclarations qu'ils font que les
parlementaires ne cache rien et sont
irréprochables et en même temps tout en
remplissant cette mission laissé à notre
assemblée elle-même son autonomie de
jugement sur ces règles de vie donc sans
finalement changé
le rapport naturel qui doit être pour
chaque à assembler entre le pouvoir
législatif et j'ai envie de dire les
autres pouvoirs puisque cette
institution on ne peut pas dire qu'elles
appartiennent à l'exécutif
elle est une production unique
législatif mais elle est à l'extérieur
comme casque à monsieur patrice il a
mais c'est le président moi je voudrais
insister sur des aspects que dix sont
mal connus de la part de notre
commission de me céder le camp je
voudrais souligner le rôle tout à fait
important qu'il a joué dans le
fonctionnement et la constitution de
l'association nationale de droit
constitutionnel dont il est un
vice-président omar câble et aussi le
fait qu'il a fait interrompre qu'il a
fait entrer le droit parlementaire à
l'intérieur de nos préoccupations de
scientifiques internationales
d'ailleurs ce délinquant et et docteur
en droit ce qui est même une
une particularité qui est importante
pour pour moi du moins et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je tiens à
souligner également le rôle qu'il a joué
dans la création d'un organisme de
recherche sur le fonctionnement des
parlements à sciences po qui est un
organisme tout à fait important qui a
étudié d'ailleurs en profondeur le
problème du cumul des mandats pour
réciter cela avec je me souviens d'une
discussion très importante que j'avais
eue avec le regretté professeur
carcassonne
donc je tiens à souligner cet aspect des
choses et je tiens à rappeler que c'est
le camp était aussi s'il ce n'est
l'inspirateur mais du moins l'un des
fondateurs du prix de thèse du sénat qui
est une réussite remarquable et qui a
permis de développer la recherche en ce
qui concerne le droit parlementaire
alors évidemment je partage entièrement
les préoccupations même tasca qui sont
également les miennes sur l'avenir de
l'institution dans lequel il va siéger
mais je n'ai pas d'autres questions à
lui poser si ce n'est qu'ils se
rappellent que je viens de mentionner
merci monsieur g l'armée chers collègues
gatti d'autres interventions
je voulais dans ce cas vous poser une
question monsieur delcamp il ne vous a
pas échappé que lors du vote de la loi
sur la transparence en nouvelle lecture
il y a eu une position différente du
sénat par rapport à celle de l'assemblée
puisque le sénat a voté la publication
au journal officiel du patrimoine des
députés et des sénateurs
l'assemblée nationale a voté le fait que
ces patrimoines seront déposés aux
préfectures et que tout citoyen électeur
pourra aller les consulter mais que la
publication de ce qui sera en quelque
sorte universellement consultables sera
agrémentée de 40000 euros d'amande et
grâce au sénat d'ailleurs nous avons pu
échapper à l'année de prison
et je vous demande si dans le monde tel
que nous le connaissons et on a parlé
tout à l'heure de l'internet
c'est quelque chose qui vous paraît
réaliste c'est à dire que si quelqu'un
va voir les déclarations à la préfecture
en fait part à un site basé à l'étranger
et que s'est reproduit dans le jour même
dans toute la presse française est ce
que il y aura une avalanche bien sûr
c'est le pouvoir judiciaire qui le
décidera de sanction de 40000 euros
damende de savoir quel était votre
appréciation bien sûr je sais bien que
vous ne pouvez pas faire autre chose que
de considérer que la loi votée en
dernière instance par l'assemblée et la
loi mais il y aura des difficultés
d'application
je voulais vous demander aussi si vous
pensez qu'en plus de son rôle de
contrôle de la haute autorité de la
transparence pourrait exercer une
mission de conseil
es qu'il peut y avoir conflit d'intérêt
aussi entre les membres de la haute
autorité par rapport à telle ou telle
que contrôle
voilà quelques qu'elle est qu'elle est
arrivée à toulouse bodog ou deux cas bon
j'ai dit ça pourrait attendre mes chers
collègues s'il y avait de nouvelles
questions de votre part il n'y a pas
d'autres questions madame d'askar vous
avez pas une nouvelle question
vous attendez monsieur jean-pierre
michel non plus monsieur jean jacques
hyest à votre question bien moi je le
connais depuis la commission des lois la
vendée ont les bien monsieur vial pas de
questions non bon alors écoutez malgré
les efforts du président vous voyez
qu'il n'y a pas de nouvelles questions
donc monsieur alain delcamp nous allons
vous redonner la parole pour répondre
aux questions que l'on peut être posée
je vous donne votre attention mes chers
collègues
merci le président j'essaierai de
réponse plus longue que les questions
mais pas trop voilà alors la première
question de madame place cas que je
salue en tant que présidente du comité
de l'anthologie du sénat est assurément
la question la plus importante pour les
assemblées parlementaires et la question
de leur autonomie est d'ailleurs très
mal comprise et les assemblées en elle
même mis du temps à comprendre que la
question de leur propre autonomie était
mal comprise et l'extérieur et je pense
que l ont entamé un effort très
remarquable et pas connu qu'à mon sens
il faut poursuivre et que si le travail
préalable qu'elles ont fait jusque là
n'avait pas existé elle aurait été dans
l'incapacité aujourd'hui d'accepter la
création d'un tel contrôle
je m'explique je crois qu'il faut dire
très très clairement et très fortement
que les parlementaires ont pris en main
leur propre destin à ce sujet qu'ils ont
élaboré des règles mis en place des
institutions
je suis très heureux de pouvoir rappeler
que le sénat a été la première
institution
la création du comité de déontologie
remonte à 2009 et ensuite
ce comité a fait des propositions
générales qui ont justifié que le bureau
du sénat invite la commission des lois à
l'époque présidée par le président
revienne à procéder à une réflexion qui
était totalement en dehors de
l'actualité parce que j'ai vu dans les
débats qu'on a dit plusieurs fois que
c'est vrai que sur la transparence était
lié à telle ou telle affaire récente non
les assemblées n'ont pas attendu ces
événements pour prendre ce type
d'affaires en main et il est heureux que
sur un sujet pareil
le législateur ait pu s'inspirer autant
des travaux du parlement que du train
des travaux des différentes commissions
fort respectable que l'exécutif avait
mis en place alors il y à aussi dans la
loi un certain nombre d'éléments qui
montrent à l'évidence que le l'autonomie
du parlement a été prise en compte
puisque aussi bien vous avez modifié
l'ordonnancé de 1958 en prévoyant
explicitement que le bureau de chaque
assemblée
après consultation de l'organe chargé de
la déontologie parlementaire détermine
les règles en matière de prêts 20 des
règles en matière de prévention et de
traitement des conflits d'intérêts il
veille à leur respect et en contre la
mise à neuf par conséquent la compétence
des instances internes au parlement est
réservé d'autre part monsieur le
président sur je crois qu'au cours des
débats vous avez fait observer qu'il n'y
avait pas dans la loi organique de
définition des conflits d'intérêts et de
fait il y en a pas
donc il ya là non pas une zone de non
droit mais je dirais une zone de droits
à construire et 100
sans aller trop loin dans ma réponse car
vous avez déjà entendu le président de
cette instance et comme c'est une
instance collégiale je m'en voudrais de
donner une opinion trop trop affirmées
je pense que des ponts sont inévitables
alors je crois que c'est sain parce que
une autorité administrative indépendante
certes mais précisément parce qu'elle
est indépendante elle doit pouvoir comme
monsieur nadal l'a dit d'ailleurs avoir
recours la coopération avec toute une
série d'institutions qui soit poursuivre
le but soit qui peuvent l'aider à
atteindre ce but
donc ma réponse est que cette
acceptation parlement par le
pardonneront deux organismes extérieurs
étaient ainsi de nature it et que son
autonomie n'est pas affectée et que hong
kong demandera peut-être mieux
quelle est sa manière c'est très
spécifique de voir les choses et puis je
me permettrai un dernier mot qui m'est
venu à l'esprit dans la réflexion qui
m'est venue à l'esprit c'est que le fait
d'avoir un regard extérieur sur le
parlement et peut être un avantage pour
lui parce qu'aujourd'hui on le soupçonne
d'être juge et partie et de faire sa
propre publicité les gens ne le
connaissent pas je crois que quand on va
le regarder de l'extérieur d'un peu plus
près et de manière bien entendu
objective on s'apercevra du travail
considérable et du fait qu'au fond les
questions de corruption et autres non
pas en france je ne sais pas un des
lieux où les tentations peut-être même
sont les plus grandes
voilà ce que je me permets de répondre
alors en ce qui concerne l'art monsieur
le doyen gélard bon je suis tout à fait
confiant de ce que vous avez bien voulu
rappeler mais je dois dire que ça m'est
toujours apparu comme une quelque chose
de nécessaire que ceux qui connaissent
le parlement et
et qu'il aime puisse en parler parce que
c'est une zone d'ombré dans la dans
l'enseignement aussi dans la perception
au canal public et je crois qu'il y a en
france une tendance naturelle peut être
est ce dû à la centralisation vous ne
sais pas une tendance naturelle qui fait
qu' on ne voit en général que l'exécutif
et enfin de croire que les législatifs
n'existe plus je crois que c'est une
erreur tout à fait essentiel on le voit
à travers vos votes
on le voit à travers les amendements on
le voit à travers l'échangé entre les
deux assemblées
le simple fait de regarder par exemple
les auditions qui ont eu lieu à
l'assemblée nationale est ici pour moi
même non non on fait mon fait dire que
le public qui voit ce genre d'exercice
ne peut qu'être impressionné par le
sérieux et pourquoi avoir attendu si
longtemps avant que l'exécutif accepte
que le parlement soit associée à des
décisions importantes pour le
fonctionnement général de la démocratie
au fond tout ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières années n'est que l'histoire
d'une reconquête par le parlement de ses
droits et de ses pouvoirs
troisième point monsieur le président ce
qui concerne la publicité
naturellement je pourrais comme vous
faire état d'un scepticisme sur
l'efficacité de mesures trop ou trop
complexes
on peut dire que on est pour la
transparence
on ne l'est pas et le sénat a montré
qu'il était allé plus loin que la loi
puisque vous avez pris l'initiative
alors que rien ne nous y oblige et de
publier vos déclaré abdou propres
déclarations
je saisirai ce point de la publicité
pour revenir sur la décision du conseil
constitutionnel parce que c'est une
décision
mon avis dont on n'a pas assez souligné
l'importance parce qu'elle a sur
beaucoup de points répondu à des
attentes du débat parlementaire mais
aussi
déboucher sur de grands changements en
matière de publicité puisque cette
mesure qui a été mis en place pour les
parlementaires n'a pas été jugée
proportionnelle et proportionnée par le
conseil constitutionnel on regarde la
protection de la vie privée pour lui les
équidés grand exécutifs locaux
j'avoue que je m'interroge sur ce sur ce
point ensuite il ya eu tout le problème
de la distinction entre la publication
des déclarations des élus et des non
élus ce qui peut à mon sens se
comprendre il ya eu aussi beaucoup
d'autres beaucoup d'autres éléments
notamment regardons la séparation des
pouvoirs
justement qui a été réaffirmée tant vis
à vis du parlement que l'autorité
judiciaire et ça me paraît très bien
quant à votre question est ce que la
haute autorité peut elle-même être
confrontés nombre de la haute autorité
peuvent être même être qu elle même être
confronté à des questions déontologiques
oui bien sûr et d'ailleurs la loi répond
puisque je crois qu il avait même été
question de temps de prévoir
l'institution de suppléeront de façon à
remplacer tel membre qui se trouvera
ayant un rapport direct ou indirect avec
telle ou telle affaire qui devrait être
été j'avoue que depuis que le président
du sénat on a fait part de sa
proposition je réfléchis à ma propre
position s'agissant des sénateurs par
exemple alors je ne sais pas si ma
préoccupation est excessive
en tout cas ça fait partie des sujets
dont il faudra naturellement parler en
amont et qui fera sans doute partie des
questions traitées par le règlement je
vous m'avez demandé aussi si la
commission on pouvait avoir aussi un
rôle de conseil
oui c'est ce cela figure je dirais dans
les mots de la loi puisque d'abord le
principe du contradictoire est assurée
c'est une autre façon d'ailleurs de
rassurer les assemblées puisque il est
évident que le bureau étant le
destinataire premier des observations de
la haute autorité s'agissant des
parlementaires pour l'occasion de faire
de faire connaître sont connus alors la
personne concernée a été mis en mesure
de produire des explications c'est la
condition
ensuite la la la haute autorité informe
répond aux demandes d'avis et mais des
recommandations établi un rapport mais
je crois que c'est un problème beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus large qui a le auquel
elle va se trouver confronté c'est pas
seulement un problème administratif ou
juridiques je dirais c'est un problème à
proprement parler de de communication il
faut qu'elle elle joue un rôle dans la
la redécouverte
je dirais des principes de la démocratie
car la transparence est une chose mais
il faut aussi veiller la liberté
d'action des décideurs politiques
il faut certes éradiquer comme l'a voulu
président de la république les racines
de la défiance
mais il faut aussi rappeler que un homme
n'est pas seulement ce qu'il a et il est
ce qu'il est et surtout comme disait
malraux ce qu'il fait et ça me paraît au
moins aussi important que de se
préoccuper de façon excessive de ce
qu'il a il n'en reste pas moins que je
suis naturellement extrêmement favorable
à cette évolution
j'ai un petit mot sur les sur les
rebondissements sur la sphère de haute
autorité sur cette question des
autorités administratives indépendantes
car dans le cadre de mes fonctions à la
commission des lois
j'ai eu la grande chance de participer à
l'élaboration enfin bon comme
fonctionnaire de la loi sur
l'informatique les fichiers et les
libertés en 1977 et c'est la première
fois que le législateur est créé
autorité administrative indépendante je
peux porter comme nous sommes si je puis
dire en situation de confiance je me
verrais ce membre de la commission des
lois et ça permettra de montrer peut
être au public commence comme on laisse
les choses
l'expression autorité administrative
indépendante est née au cours d'une
réunion de travail qui s'est tenue chez
le rapporteur jacques- au en compagnie
des revers tunnel qui devait être à
l'époque je pense doyens de facultés
droit d'orléans
s'il se veut bien malheureusement nous a
quittés les deux nous ont quittés nous
étions 3 et c'est là qu'est née cette
idée car que vous voulez le législateur
fêté au fond avoir un outil qui veille à
l'application des lois et qui ne soit
pas le seul exécutif
donc c'était un assez original l'époque
compte tenu du caractère assez rigide et
institutions françaises que de définir
un espace monsieur michel le sait
puisqu'il elle siégeait la cnil de
définir un espace qui soit plus tout à
fait l'exécutif et qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas être d'une vraie prolongement du
pouvoir législatif
donc il fallait trouver il fallait
résoudre la contradiction et on l'a
résolu par parle pluralisme par l'idée
d'indépendance et par la suite je dirais
l'aspect administratif peut être repris
un peu d'importance donc peut-être que
cette nouvelle haute autorité pourra
montrer que l' équilibre indépendance et
et administration est un équilibre
évolutif et qui se développera d'autant
mieux que elle saura avoir la sagesse de
bien se situer dans l'ensemble des
pauvres en public étant entendu que sa
mission est une mission d'abord et
essentiellement démocratique bien mes
chers collègues je pense que nous
pouvons remercier monsieur alain delcamp
qui s'est efforcé de nous apporter des
réponses très précises aux questions que
nous avons posées y compris sur des
questions qui pourraient être délicates
comme celle le du conflit d'intérêts y
compris par rapport aux membres de la
haute autorité donc il n'y a pas
d'autres questions mes chers collègues
pas de scrupules
monsieur françois pilée avec l'aimable
et pressante invitation du président je
veux bien rajouter une question très
subtil hier le biais d'accords oui
excusez moi une question très subtil
hier d'autant plus aisée que le sénat
n'est pas à l'origine de la loi telle
qu'elle est le sénat était allé beaucoup
plus loin comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure je voulais revenir sur la
publication la volonté du législateur
s'est en quelque sorte de faire que la
publication soit radicalement interdite
puisque il a prévu une pénalité se dit
très importante même si au départ la
prévoyait encore plus importante pour
s'assurer du respect de la volonté du
législateur
il faut donc pouvoir retrouver celui qui
serait à l'origine de la divulgation
pour ce faire on peut prendre
éventuellement des précautions en amont
est ce qu il serait concevable que dans
le cadre
d'une comment dirais-je de documents
conservés sous la foi du secret
préfectorale celui qui consulte celui
qui consulte le nom de celui qui
consulte soit conservée par la
préfecture afin que le jour où liée
entre guillemets une fuite on puisse
plus facilement remonter à l'auteur de
la fuite et de ce fait donné une
certaine efficacité à la mesure prise
par les députés dans mon esprit de bien
évident que ces informations ne seraient
pas communiquées aux parlementaires ou
hautement fassions veut donner de
l'efficacité à la loi faut trouver des
systèmes en amont monsieur piles et
madame parce qu'à vous en prie vous qui
connaissez fort bien le droit
parlementaire des pays voisins
est-ce que vous pensez que la haute
autorité aura intérêt à tisser des liens
étroits avec les instances déontologique
notamment à l'échelle européenne
et est ce que vous pensez qu'elle aurait
intérêt à s'inscrire dans une sorte de
réseau des changes des organes
comparables je sais que nous cultivons
beaucoup l'exception française mais le
regard sur ce qui se fait par oui
voila voila je fais de la question donc
de nouvelles gares de nouvelles
questions monsieur dalcan oui sur la
mise en oeuvre du dispositif j'avoue que
il faut sans doute attendre le décret en
conseil d'état
à ce sujet je comme je crois monsieur
nadal l'a dit mais je le soutiendrai
fortement sur ce point je pense qu'il
serait hautement souhaitable que ce
décret soit certain conseil d'état mais
qu'il soit élaboré en concertation avec
au moins le président de la commission
de même qu'il y a plusieurs décrets qui
sont prévus dans la loi après avis de la
commission nationale informatique et
libertés
ça n'est pas simplement pour les mêmes
techniques je pense que savoir comment
sont rédigées déclaration n'est pas
neutre et il serait bon que pouvoir
exécutif qui tienne compte aussi de la
vie la commission parce que je parlais
tout à l'heure l'application des lois
c'est un sujet qui intéresse beaucoup le
sénat je crois que ce qui est souvent
oubliée c'est le respect de l'esprit
dans lequel le législateur a voté telle
ou telle disposition et il manque
assurément ça a été développée mais on
peut toujours faire mieux il manque
assurément un contrôle du du contrôleur
si je puis dire de manière à ce que les
choses soient faites au mieux en ce qui
concerne la sphère des réseaux moi je
pense qu on a toujours intérêt à savoir
ce qui se passe à l'étranger
je ne crois pas non plus que soit une
panacée d'autant que pour qu'il puisse y
avoir la constitution de réseaux il faut
des organismes comptables
or autant je crois qu'un réseau des
parlements pour savoir comment les
parlements établissent leur propre
déontologie me paraît indispensable
je vous l'avez sans doute en tantale est
autant une comparaison d'intérêts
autorité semblables j'avoue je ne
connais pas assez la question mais j'ai
l'intuition que ne devons pas être très
nombreux avoir créé une autorité
nationale qui s'occupe de tout donc
des méthodes oui savoir s'il ya un point
important c'est savoir au fond
quels sont les critères à partir
desquels on considère qu'il ya conflit
d'intérêt à l'étranger
et si nous sommes au 22e rang ça n'est
pas parce que nous sommes le 22e pays le
plus corrompu ce c'est absolument pas ça
je fais partie d'une génération qui a
toujours pensé que dit le mot même de
corruption étaient absents de
l'administration je peux complètement
naïf mais je crois qu'il y avait tout de
même une éthique du service public et
qui prévenait assez largement des
comportements qui existait dans d'autres
pays froid qu'il faut tout de même le
dire et aujourd'hui nous sommes un peu
victimes je dirais de d'une certaine une
adaptation de notre propre modèle et
nous avons beaucoup de mal à l'adapter
parce que il est tellement cohérent il
était tellement cohérent il était
tellement beau si je puis dire qu'on a
du mal à y renoncer
or je pense que nous sommes comme disent
les philosophes
le président connaît bien nous sommes
face à une open opérations de
déconstruction reconstruction
hier il faut déconstruire reçu derrida
qui approche nous sommes obligés dé
construire notre modèle pour savoir
comment intégrer des idées qui sont pas
les nôtres
tout en ne renions pas notre originalité
et ce problème des conflits d'intérêts
est typique de des mauvais jugement qui
sont faits sur la france parce que ce
sont les lunettes que nous connaissons
pas et il faut connaître les lunettes à
travers lesquelles on va être gardé pour
s'y conformer
et ne pas confondre cela avec l'idée que
nous n'aurions pas pris autant de
précautions que les autres c'est
totalement faux puisque cette loi
précisément et un moment temporaire
certes provisoire mais c'est un peu le
couronnement d'une évolution car on a
parlé
de la succession des lois qui vont peu à
peu circonscrits la question de de la
probité
c'est le mot qui dans la loi des
parlementaires mais il y à aussi
parallèlement toute une série d'autres
textes qui font qu'il y à un ensemble
global de réflexion pour faire en sorte
que pour reprendre à nouveau le mot du
président république
les racines de la défiance au éradiquer
je crois que c'est ça c'est ça la vraie
question donc le parlement n'est pas du
tout le sujet premier essai ce que à
titre personnel dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui je pouvais le dire peut-être
plus facilement
ça fait partie des choses que j'ai
l'intention de dire bien mes chers
collègues il ne me reste à remercie en
votre nom à tous ah oui il ya une ultime
question il faut faire attention pour
l'horaire monsieur y ait cette remarque
le conseiller s'en fiche alors oui non
mais je sais nous sommes enfin je sais
pas si on s'en fiche
leroy pas blanc que mais soyons nous
sommes tout à fait vous avez vous savez
a pas seulement les parlementaires il ya
les élus locaux
bien sûr et alors là on peut peut-être
que c'est pas tout à fait le même point
de vue en ce qui concerne les dangers
alors dans monsieur y est merci de cet
ultime question de cette ultime remarque
nous sommes tout à fait à tâcher nous
sommes tout à fait attacher à la
séparation des pouvoirs
et après tout le sénat statuera quand il
reste quand il le décidera et quand il
l'aura fait nous sommes contraints par
aucune autre considération
cela n'appelle pas de réponse monsieur y
est bien merci pour la remarque qu'au
final mes chers collègues je crois que
nous avons eu plaisir à entendre
monsieur alain delcor nous aurons
d'ailleurs à nouveau je pense le plaisir
de poursuivre ses débats très
intéressants
voilà vous avez pu suivre l'audition
d'alain dalcan alain delcamp qui a été
nommé
membre de la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique
dans un instant 24 heures sénat présenté
par delphine girard